Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Five Nights At Freddy's: Sister Location.
Now, there's a few things that I wanna talk about
before we get started.
Number One! These security cameras here...
Who's watching those cameras?
Because in the last one when I edited the video,
Baby and her crew said...
'SHE'S watching us.' not HE'S watching us.
'SHE'S watching us.'
So who is that, is that the voice on the intercom
Is the voice on the intercom actually Baby,
and is the Baby, those little voices in there
just the babies in there?
So there's a lot of mysteries here.
Also this! *Dying baby sound*
Eeugh.
This! (Squeaky clown horn)
This! (Distorted noise)
And this last one... Doesn't do anything.
And neither does that.
So anyways that's a whole bunch of stuff that's not important right now
We're gonna get back to Freddy's lil' room here and try to beat that.
[Female Voice] Ballora gallery maintenance vent opened.
[Mark] First, we got to get through Ballora
DANAHNAHNAHNAH
Ballora
Don't kill me
BANAHNAHNAHNAH
(Music box plays)
Sneaking!
Make it-
AHHHH
(Door opening)
Yeah!
Suck on that. Okay, so, I'm pretty sure my prob-
[Female Voice] Motion trigger breaker room.
[Hand Unit] You may now interface with the breaker control box
[Mark] Okay
[Hand Unit] Using the interface may disrupt nearby electronics.
If you feel you are in danger, feel free to disconnect the interface temporarily
until it is safe to reconnect
[Mark] uh huh.
Okay, soooo, I think my problem here was, I tried to do too many at once?
(Steady electronic beeping)
Like, obviously, the danger is going to be... bad?
(Funtime Freddy laughs)
(Steady electronic beeping)
[Funtime Freddy] Well, hello again!
[Bon-Bon] Calm down,
[Bon-Bon] and go back to sleep!
[Mark, extended] Hi!
(Extended) Hi!
HO, Okay!
He moves!
I did not know he moved!
Eugh!
[Funtime Freddy] Bon-Bon, say 'Hi' to our friend!
[Bon-Bon] Go back to your stage, everything is okay.
[Mark] Is it? Is everything okay? I don't know about that.
So, it does save a little bit of progress
but I gotta listen for, the shuffle-y shoe of a- of a wild bear
[Bon-Bon] Everything is okay,
[Mark] But I gotta listen for, the shuffle-y shoe of a- of a wild bear
[Bon-Bon] Let's go back to sleep.
[Mark] Oh Jeez
Oh yeah, go back to sleep, oh God, hi!
[Mark] How are you doing? Oh!
[Bon-Bon] Oh, calm down!
[Bon-Bon] I think it was just a mouse!
[Mark] GO!
GO!!
RUEHHHHH
Hup-
[Bon-Bon] Nnnope! No one is here!
(Mark grunts)
[Mark] Ha, ha, no one's here! Oh my god, that smile.
(Laughs) That- That winning smile
(Steady beeping)
It's so nice.
Okay.
That's a shuffle. That's a shu-VRR
[Bon-Bon] It's bedtime! Let's go back to our stage.
[Mark] I think
I think the little voice is Bonnie,
(Laugh-crying) but Bonnie is talking to Funtime Freddy
and that's not a happy duo!
Well it's happy for the-
GO!
[Bon-Bon] You didn't hear anything, silly! (Giggle)
[Funtime Freddy] I know you're over there somewhere!
[Mark]...And who's that voice?
[Funtime Freddy] Bon-Bon!
[Bon-Bon] Go back to your stage!
[Funtime Freddy] I Th-think thats the birthday boy over there!
[Bon-Bon] Everything is okay.
[Funtime Freddy] We should give them a surprise!
[Mark] Who- who's talking about Bon--
Who's talkin to Bon-Bon-
(High-pitched) IS THAT FREDDY?
[Bon-Bon] Everything is okay
[Bon-Bon] Let's go back to sleep.
[Mark] Is that Freddy's voice?
Why does Freddy sound like such a douche?
And.
AH!
[Hand Unit] Great job.
This completes your tasks for the night.
Please proceed back through the Ballora gallery with care.
And we'll see you back here tomorrow.
[Mark] Yes!
I did it!
I could have done that in the last episode
(Laughing) I didn't know that was gonna end right there.
Woo!
(Exhales)
I feel lightheaded.
(Door shuts)
....Oh god no.
Oh god, not again
Da na na na na na na na nun.
Sneaking.
(Quieter) Da na na na na na na na nun...
Ballora.
DA NA NA NA-
[Ballora] Is someone there?
[Mark]...nnnnnNNOOOOoo.
Go back to SLEEP!
I think it was (laugh) just a mouse!
[Ballora] I can hear someone creeping through my room...
[Mark] (High-pitched noise) Buh-- no don't think so.
I think-- (Wheezes)
I think those appeared-- LIES!
eh
Eh
[Ballora] Perhaps... not.
[Mark] Heh, yeah.
That's the one.
You don't need to worry about me!
I just need to worry about me!
AND DON'T MIND THE YELLING.
I YELL WHEN I'M NERVOUS.
Okay.
(Happy celebration music)
Oh!
Ooh~!
(Singing) /We did it! We're the best in the world!/
/And! We~ are friends! For--/
(Music ends abruptly) Oh.
Ever.
Okay. Anyway. I guess-
My friend song is over.
Oh good- back to my soaps!
[TV annoucer] As the sun sets,
so also does another chapter in the saga of love lost
between Vlad and his distressed mistress.
Can they be reconciled?
( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)Mark moans( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Can their love rise again?
That and more, happening now.
[Mark] I- I, (laugh) I have no idea--
[Vlad] Clara! The baby isn't mine!
[Clara] It is, Vlad!
They had trouble catching him in the nursery today.
[Vlad] So what? Lots of kids get hyper
and run around and stuff.
[Clara] They had to knock him out of the air with a BROOM!
[Vlad] ...I have to go.
[Clara] They're going to dock your paychecks!
[Vlad] They can't do that!
I am a vampire! I don't get paychecks.
[Clara] You work the graveyard shift
at the Fry-Me Taco.
Don't lie to me!
(Mark laughs)
[TV announcer] Ohhh the humanity.
[Mark] Ohhh!
[Announcer] When will the heartbreak end?
When will these two ships passing in the night
rekindle their long lost love?
Tune in tomorrow to find out.
[Mark] My god.
It's so bizarre because I imagine this is trying
to paint this guy's existence as a normal, everyday Joe
And he just- After he's done working he goes home--
[Little Girl Voice] Daddy, just once let me go play with her.
She's so pretty and shiny.
Didn't you make her just for me?
[Mark] Mmm...
Ok, so what's interesting about that is that voice
I believe is the daughter of Mr. Ashton. (Mr. Asshat)
[Hand Unit] Welcome back to another pivotal night of your thriving new career,
where you get to really ask yourself,
(Mark laughs)
"What am I doing with my life?"
(Mark laughs again)
"What would my friends say?"
(Mark laugh-cries)
...and most importantly, "Will I ever see my family again?"
(Mark cries)
We understand the stresses of a new job,
and we're here for you.
To help you reach a more stable and
relaxing frame of mind, we offer several musical
selections to help make this elevator ride as relaxing
and therapeutic as possible.
[Mark] Aww.
[Hand Unit] We offer contemporary jazz, classical,
rainforest ambience,
as well as a wide selection of other choices.
[Mark] Cool!
[Hand Unit] Using the keypad below,  please
type the first few letters of the musical selection you would prefer.
[Mark] Sure!
[Hand Unit] It seems you had some trouble with the keypad.
I see what you were trying to type, and I will
[Mark] Dubstep?
autocorrect it for you.
[Hand Unit] Thank you for selecting...
Casual Bongos.
(Mark laughs)
[Mark, laughing] Casual Bongos?
(Casual bongos start playing)
[Mark] Oh yeah!
[Hand Unit] Now that your elevator
experience has been customized to your needs,
(Casual bongos continue)
and you're thoroughly relaxed, it's worth mentioning
that due to your lackluster performance yesterday,
your pay has been decreased by a substantial amount.
Please enjoy the rest of your descent.
[Mark] What?!
(Casual bongos continue)
These "Casual Bongos" have turned sour!
How can you say that? What did I do?
Well, come on!
Oh, also, Mr. Ashton (Mr. Asshat) apparently is a character in the books
And apparently...
That's Purple Guy.
Whoever that is, is Purple Guy, but then that would make
Purple Guy the creator of this- these animatronics,
so what does it all mean?
(Yelling) CAN WE CUT THE "CASUAL BONGOS?!"
(Huffs)
Is it gonna- is the bongos just follow me--
(Bongos stop)
[Hand Unit] Due to unforeseen malfunctions from
today's shows, your nightly duties will require you to perform maintenance
that you may or may not be skilled enough to perform.
[Mark] Oh.
[Hand Unit] It became necessary for technicians to
attempt to disconnect Funtime Freddy's power module.
However, they were unsuccessful.
Allowing them to try again would be an
inefficient path forward, as we would need to allow six
to eight weeks for recovery and physical therapy.
You will need to reach the Parts and Service Room on the other side of Funtime Auditorium
to perform the procedure yourself.
Let's check on Ballora first, and make sure she's on her stage.
[Mark] Uh--
(Lights buzz as they turn on)
[Emphatically] UH!
[Hand Unit] Great. It looks like everything is as it should
be at Ballora Gallery.
(Mark wheezes repeatedly)
Let's check on Funtime Foxy.
It's important to make sure she's on her stage before entering.
[Mark] Ugh! Okay, so this Foxy is definitely a "fuh-mail"(female)?
But, you know, that's a revelation that's gonna have to
go in second place to what the fuck I just saw over on Ballora's stage.
EHHH
(Lights buzz as they turn on)
Ok, never-- you know, never mind, maybe I shouldn't be so worried about it.
Oh, yeah, Foxy's gone.
[Hand Unit] Great, it looks like everything
is as it should be in Funtime Auditorium.
(Mark makes confused sounds)
There is no need to check on Baby tonight.
Please refrain from entering unauthorized areas.
Proceed directly to Funtime Auditorium.
[Mark] I- Excuse me? Are you tryina' tell me what to do?
How dare you! I'm'una go straight into Baby's room,
and check on Baby!
'Cos, if there's one thing that Markiplier is, it's a good daddy, and I'm'na check on Baby.
Eugh...
Ok, so what've we got over here? Alright.
Baby! Oh, boy...
I--
I don't think I should be here.
I'm pretty sure I shouldn't be here.
Is there any reason for this?
Do I need to be here?
(Metallic clank)
(Metal grating)
Is there a point?
Hmm...
[Circus Baby] Did you know that I was on stage once?
It wasn't for very long.
Only one day...
What a wonderful day, though.
I was in a small room with balloons and a few tables.
No one sat at the tables, though.
But children would run in and out.
Some were afraid of me. Others enjoyed my songs.
Music was always coming from somewhere else.
Down a hall.
I would always count the children.
I'm not sure why.
I was always acutely aware of how many there were in the room with me.
Two, then three, then two, then three, then four, then two.
Then none.
They usually played together in groups of two or three.
I was covered in glitter.
I smelled like birthday cake.
There were two, then three, then five, then four.
I can do something special.
Did you know that?
I can make ice cream.
Although I only did it once...
There were four, then three, then two.
(Nearby whisper) Then one.
Something happened when there was one.
A little girl, standing by herself.
I was no longer...
myself.
And I stopped singing.
My stomach opened,
and there was ice cream.
(Distressed) I couldn't move, at least, not until she stepped closer.
(Defensively) There was screaming for a moment, but only for a moment.
Then other children rushed in again, but they couldn't hear her over the sounds of their own excitement.
I still hear her sometimes.
Why did that happen?
(Silence)
(Mark screams)
[Mark] I- EUH That painted a VERY vivid picture
of something EXCEPTIONALLY FUCKED
Let me try to rationalize exactly what she was talking about there.
She, uh..
She was on stage once with balloons and such not, some sort of birthday party establishment
and then, uh,
there was one girl in the room,
and it's entirely possible- It's entirely possible that that one girl
was the daughter of Mr. Ashton (Mr. Asshat), who is the Purple Guy, supposedly,
and the Purple Guy made this animatronic in her- his daughter's image
(Horrified laugh) and then it made ice cream out of her??
(Laughter continues) Or maybe not, I don't know...
Oh, that's horrifying. Euh, that's so horrifying...
But that would make sense...
Unless her counting thing was only looking for an opportunity for there to BE one person in the room,
(Laugh) and then... Euh, man, either way...
HWOOO, I am not glad I came in here.
I regret that very much, so let's skedaddle on out of here and continue on to Funtime Foxy because hoh--
[Female Voice] Motion trigger. Circus gallery vent.
[Mark] Hoooly shit.
Hyaah, boy..
That's interesting though, because that's the first time I've ever encountered
like a deliberate Easter Egg in this game. Everything else
has been random chance, but that's the first time you could like,
incidentally go to something and reveal more of the story, so,
let's carry on to Funtime Foxy and reca--
(Interrupting metal squeak)
(Door opens)
[Female Voice] Funtime Auditorium maintenance vent opened.
(Door closes)
[Hand Unit] Unlike Ballora, Funtime Foxy is motion activated.
For this reason, it's important to keep the room dark, as to not accidentally activate her.
You have been provided with a flash beacon.
Use it if you need to get your bearings, and to ensure you don't bump into anything.
However, use it as sparingly as possible.
Proceed forward to reach the Parts and Service Room.
[Mark] Ok...
huhPOOF
(Flash noise)
...the fuck, I didn't see anything!
(Light recharging)
huhpoof
(Flash)
Oh boy
(Light recharging)
(Small movement noise)
huhpoof (Flash)
OIIIIEEEEEEEEEE
(Light recharging)
(Footsteps)
(Quickly) Huhpoof!
(Flash)
(Light recharging)
(Quiet, distressed noise)
(Funtime Foxy screams)
(Mark screams)
AAAaaa...
(Static)
(Exhale)
Ok... Ohhhwhat the fuuuuck
(Turtle Crusher plays)
What the fuuck
Aaahhh...
(Laugh) Oh, I got cupcakes!
Hoooh
Hi!
Wh-- wh
W-whoa
(Laugh) Oh, boy
This seems, uh...
This seems not so good.
(Laugh) I- I'm not entirely sure I understand exactly what's going on here,
but something tells me it's- it's not entirely good
(Laugh) Oh, it's a shotgun of cupcake- huhBAH
Alright, you wanna- you wanna cupcake? Ok, I'll get both of ya
HABUSKI
Oh, yeah, you all enjoy your cupcakes.
Habuhah
What is happening here?
(Laugh) What is going on?
I have no idea!
You want one, kid? hABUH
Aw, man, I'm outta cups. Aw, man, I'm outta cakes.
Oh jeez- Oh, a green one?
Well that- That sounds good.
What does this do?
Do I even wanna know?
Ooh, it carries through-- Goddamit, I wish I knew what these things did before I used them.
Dangit.
Oh, dangit, aw dagnabit
Well, we're just gonna have one kid without it, so,
that's nice.
I don't- I don't have any! I don't have any, you guys are all screeewed!
I'm literally out, how do you expect me to do anything?
Oh, boy
Whwhwhwaitwowwahwoah
Woahwoahwoahwoah
(Grunts)
Ok you guys are just gonna...
do without, 'cos... what can I do?
Wooo!
Hell, yeah!
I made it!
Oh, game over, I forgot that I died.
Well, alright then... So, that's a thing.
Okey
[Hand Unit] You have been provided with a flash beacon.
(Funtime Foxy screams)
(Mark screams)
(Static)
[Mark] HEY, WHAT THE FUCK!
I, uh...
got /boned/.
So uh, don't just walk forward in the dark is the uh- thethethe name of the game, there.
Ok, so when I hear a movement in the darkness,
I think that's...
Foxy moving around, so I'm gonna wait until I hear, like a sound
That signifies, like...
'in front of me?'
(Flash)
(Funtime Foxy screams)
[Mark, shouting] Oh, why?!
WHY?
(Extended) WHY?
Ah, jeez-
I dunno- heh
(Flash)
(Light recharging)
(Foot steps)
(Funtime Foxy screams)
Mark: HEY
AW, COME ON, MAN-
I thought I had that-
I thought there was a distinct sound when she moves in front of you and
then a distinct sound when she moves away-
oo boy-
oooo boy.
yeah- I'm just gonna take my time on this one.
I'm gonna wait-
a good, LONG time-
between each movement-
seems to be working, it just taking a long time.
My theory is that there's a reason
they have the sound, for the recharging.
(Flash)
(Light recharging)
So it acts like, as a, it acts like as a timer
for...
how long it takes to cool down Foxy.
So hopefully that's a better way of going about it but
I don't know for sure
but it seems to be working.
(Flash)
(Light recharging)
(Movement/banging noise)
(Singing) ooOOOOOOOOOOOOOOH--
I DON'T KNOW I HOPE I DON'T-
wOOOOOH
[Female Voice] Motion trigger: Parts and Service.
[Hand Unit] Great job reaching Parts and Service.
It seems that Funtime Freddy is out of power,
which should make your job much easier.
[Mark] oh
[Hand Unit]The release switch for the chest cavity is located on the underside of the endoskeleton jaw.
To reach it, we will first need to open the face plates.
[Mark] aaAAAAAAAH
[Hand Unit]You will need to press the faceplate release triggers in a specific order,
and it's important to be as precise, and as careful, as possible.
[Mark] (Small, scared noise)
[Hand Unit] Locate the small button on Freddy's face, just under his right cheek, and press it.
[Mark] OH.
ok
[Hand Unit] Great. Now locate the button under his left cheek, and press it.
Mark: [Screaming]
[Mark]  I DID THE WRONG CHEEK
(High pitched) OH GOD!!!!
No, I did the right cheek, I did his right, okay
ho
[Hand Unit] Great. Now carefully locate and press the button next to Freddy's right eye.
[Mark] This one?
okay-
[Hand Unit] Great! Now carefully locate and press the button just above Freddy's nose.
[Mark] Ok.
hEEEEEYYYY
goD DAMN IT
[Hand Unit] Good job.
[Mark] Fuck you.
[Hand Unit] The face plates should now be open.
[Mark] eeeuuUUUGH
[Hand Unit] Locate and press the small button on the underside of Freddy's endoskeleton jaw.
[Mark] hUUUUH-
UHHH Here?
(Metal springlocks release)
EEEEEEEH
[Hand Unit] Excellent. The chest cavity should now be open.
Remove the power module from the chest cavity.
[Mark] HOW?
Ooooh, god
OOOOooooh god, I hate this-
Why is he over here?
[Hand Unit] Great work. You will now be required to remove the secondary power module
from the Bonnie hand puppet.
[Mark] oh. OOOH
[Hand Unit] Press the large black button beneath Bonnie's bow tie to release the power module.
[Mark] UUH
UUH
Uh huh, uh huh, hey hey
hey, hey, hey, hey, heyyy
I uhh, uhhh, uhhhh *close your eyes( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)*
uh- how- do I-
how do I do this?
wHAT
I doN'T LIKE THAT
How in the fuck am I supposed to do this?
eUUUH
Am I supposed to I thought it was under the jaw, or is it his nose I'm supposed to boop
Am I supposed to boop his nose?
[Hand Unit] Press the large, black button beneath Bonnie's bow tie to release the power module.
Uhhh, I would, I just- I- He won't show it to me, dude-!
(Shuffling noises)
(Bon-Bon screams)
oOOOOH-
AAAAH, COME ON-
HOW THE FUCK?!
I see him.
Oh, he's slowly rising, okay, he's sloWLY RISING, If I can just
catch him, enough
aaaaaAAH, boink~
I go- I GOT THAT!!
OH I SO GOT THAT!
God damn it, okay.
he's gonna rise, he's gonna rise, RISE.
lil' more-
'lil more
little more
I gotcha, I gotcha, I gotcha ah, YEAAAAH!!!
[Hand Unit] Great job.
[Mark] BITCH.
[Hand Unit] You've acquired both power modules.
This completes your tasks for the night.
[Mark] YEEEEEEAAAAAAH
[Hand Unit] Please exit the building through Funtime Auditorium,
[Mark] fffffffFFFFFFF-
[Hand Unit] and we'll see you back here again tomorrow.
[Mark] ffFFFRICK. How am I gonna be able to get back?
Holy shit.
(Door closes)
Fuck.
Fuuck.
(Flash)
(Light recharging)
(Footsteps)
(Mark groans)
Foxy's not gonna talk to me like Ballora did.
It's just gonna be me
versus her.
And that's fine.
That's totally okay.
So you CAN run, in between,
but you have to wait the long periods of time for her to really cool down,
and then flash, make sure it's clear, and then gun it.
it's the only thing you can do.
'Cause otherwise, if you run, just in the dark, you're gonna die.
but I'm not gonna- I'M NOT GONNA TEST MY THEORY
IN DEFINITELY
I'M GONNA WAIT
very patiently
to make sure that I do not die
cause' I don't wanna do all that AGAAAAIN!
Frick!
(Flash)
(Funtime Foxy screams)
OH, COME ON!!
OH FUCK YOU, GOD DAMN IT
FUCK OFF!!!
[Little girl voice] Daddy, she can make balloons!
Have you seen her make balloons?
Oh, Daddy, let me go to her...
[Mark, whispering] What?
What?
What??
WHAT?
[Circus Baby] Shh. Be still. And quiet.
[Mark] Why?
[Circus Baby] You've been sleeping for quite a while.
[Mark] Huh?
[Circus Baby] I think they noticed that you never left the building last night.
The cameras were searching for you.
But they couldn't find you.
I have you hidden too well.
(Whisper) I kidnapped you.
[Mark] Oh.
(Cheery music)
wHAAAAAT?
HUUUUUUUH?!
What the fuuuck?
[Circus Baby] Don't be afraid. I'm not going to hurt you.
[Mark] Uh huh. Yeah, sure. Okay.
[Circus Baby] I am only going to keep you for a little while.
[Mark] Why?
[Circus Baby] Try not to wiggle, though.
You're inside something that came from my old pizzeria.
I don't think it was ever used.
At least not the way it was meant to be used.
[Mark] What?
[Circus Baby] Too dangerous.
It's just big enough for one person to fit inside.
But just... barely.
[Mark] Oh!
Am I in, like, one of those s-
[Circus Baby] You're in the scooping room.
Do you know why they call it the scooping room?
[Mark] NO!
[Circus Baby] It's because, dummy
this is the room where they use the scooper.
I thought that would be obvious.
[Mark] Okay.
[Circus Baby] Isn't that a fun name for something?
[Mark] NO.
[Baby] "The Scooper."
[Mark] Maybe.
[Circus Baby] It sounds like something you would use for ice cream.
Or custard. Or sprinkles
It sounds like something you would want at your birthday party
to ensure that you get a heaping portion of every. Good. Thing.
I wonder, though.
If you were a freshly opened pint of ice cream,
how you would feel about something with that name?
Thankfully, I don't think a freshly opened pint of ice cream feels anything at all.
Uh oh.
It sounds like someone else is in the building.
Shh.
[Mark, whispering] What...
[Maintenance man 1] Okay, bring her over. Forward. More.
Mooore okay, stop.
Set her down.
Waatch the step.
[Maintenance man 2] What happened to it this time?
Just seems like these things can't go a day without breaking down.
[Maintenance man 1] Who knows? It's always the same, man, some kind of hardware malfunction.
[Maintenance man 2] Well, hey I have to be somewhere in fifteen minutes. This place gives me the creeps.
Can we just get this over with? It's all automated. We don't have to be here for it.
Just get her on some rollers, then we can go.
(Door closes)
(Mechanical whirring, rattling, and banging noises)
[Mark] HOOOOOH
HOOOOOOOOOOHHHH
OOOOOOOOOOOH!
HEY!
(Mechanical whirring, rattling, and banging noises continue)
(Mechanical noises stop abruptly)
Oh.
Oh, Okay
Ah, ahoh
[Circus Baby] There's something very important that I've learned how to do over time. Do you know what that is?
[Mark] No!
You gonna tell me?
[Circus Baby] How to pretend.
Do you ever play make believe?
[Mark] Tha- No.
[Circus Baby] Pretend to be one way, when you are really the other...
[Mark] (Whine) no....
[Circus Baby] It's very important.
Ballora never learns.
But I do.
[Mark] Huh?
[Circus Baby] They think there is something wrong, on the inside.
The only thing that matters is knowing. How. To. Pretend.
(Industrial beeping)
(scooper starts hitting Ballora)
[Mark]: aaAAhh
ooOH
OOOOOOOH
[Circus Baby] I'll open the faceplates for you.
[Mark] I don't want it.
[Circus Baby] That way, they can find you on the cameras.
[Mark] I doN'T WANT THAT!!
[Circus Baby] Now all you have to do, is wait.
[Mark] AAAAAAWww...
[Circus Baby] I'd recommend that you keep the springlocks wound up.
Your breathing and your heartbeat are causing them to come loose.
[Mark] Oh, oh, oh, oh oh
[Circus Baby] You don't want them to get too loose.
[Mark] oHOH oH
[Circus Baby] Trust me.
[Mark] oH OH OH OH OH OH, OH NO
OH, Okay, okay
Okay, How do I- Oh
Okay
(Clicking as springlocks unwind)
I just gotta click and hold on em
mmMM
MMMMFH
EEEEMPH
🎵WHY IS BALLORA LOOKIN' AT ME? WHY IS BALLORA LOOKIN' AT ME?🎵
WHY DID I WIGGLE SO DAMN MUCH?
oh, hi, whO THE FUCK IS THAT??!!
WHAT THE FUCK ARE YOU?!
I'LL LOOK AT YOU IN JUST A SECOND, BUT HOLY SHIT!!
(Minireena screams)
(Mark screams)
aaAAAAAH FUCK OFF!!!
(Static)
WHAT THE FUCK?!
WHAT WAS THAT?
WHAT WAS THAAAT?
What was that?
What do I do? I dunno.
Okay, that's all the time I have for this episode here.
Wow. This is just wild.
Like everything that I knew is thrown out the window, and it's all new stuff which is good
a-and it kinda ties together with something that I realized, that
you know, when Scott first announced this game and released the first trailer
It didn't even have Five Nights at Freddie's in the name, if you look back at the trailer on youtube, it just says "Sister Location Trailer One."
And I think there's a point to that.
We're not at Freddy Fazbear's pizzeria.
We're just not.
Like that's not why we're here.
This is whole new experience. So I'm gonna continue this in another episode
so thank everybody so much watching.
And as always, I will see you...
IN THE NEXT VIDEO.
BUH-BYE!
(Outro music)